[Musique]
les troisièmes entretien du patrimoine
de l'océan indien se déroule cette année
à la réunion
trois jours de discussions et de débats
autour du thème patrimoine mise en
valeur et perspectives touristiques et
j'espère bien qu'on puisse partager
vivons dans chacun de nos pays
les expériences partagées qu'on puisse
construire ni région océan indien indien
de l'océan indien est beaucoup plus
forte tout en profitant et en valorisant
pour ce qu'ils nous avons comme à tous
les atours j'en parle même des gens nous
mêmes contacts individus ne sont
dépeints potentiel pour développer notre
région mais aussi ses partage des idées
des connaissances et des savoirs cet
événement international réunit plus de
30 spécialistes universitaires
chercheurs urbanistes conservateur le
département de la réunion participe à
ces échanges et valorise ses actions
patrimonial comme sur le site de la
grande chaloupe
c'est un patrimoine qu'il ya vraiment un
fort potentiel et qui est en train
d'être valorisé puisque on a fait la
réhabilitation du lazaret numéro un qui
est terminée et aujourd'hui on est en
train de de valoriser le lazaret numéro
deux à travers un chantier d'insertion
et de professionnels
professionnalisation c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire que nous avons ouvert
au public lors des journées européennes
du patrimoine
le patrimoine c'est pas seulement sur
une sur un territoire c'est sur tout le
territoire de la réunion
c'est l'histoire de l'art elles donc le
département un rôle majeur
les participants originaires de onze
pays partagent leur expérience et leur
savoir-faire avec comme ambition faire
du patrimoine un moteur de développement
économique et touristique
[Musique]